bestellt noch mal schuhe dann noch eine
jacke und ein bisschen tower 2 die zeit
läuft ab du hast nach zwei minuten und
bitte es ist ja richtig bequem der
studie
ich habe selten so einen bequemen stuhl
gesessen hey was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch hier das
obwohl doch du kannst auch du bist da
schon auf und die aufnahme kann es mir
dann schicken auf jeden fall habe ich
heute meinen bruder dabei der merlin der
weiß auch schon länger schwer dabei ich
glaube das letzte mal wirklich dass wir
das frisch gemacht habe wurde und wir
dazwischen damals gemacht ja das mit dem
pool aber nachher gut auf jeden fall
mache ja zurzeit day you tube videos
also jeden tag kommt wiederum 10
schreibtisch oder die ohren und ich habe
mich letztes mal mit der seite wobei
befasst das ist so ähnlich wie wish
allerdings ein bisschen anders aufgebaut
und es gibt auch ein paar andere sachen
als bayerisch ich hab da zum beispiel
schon eine playstation controller
bestellt ein zwei sachen werden auch
noch ankommen allerdings fehlen noch
viele sachen also man könnte noch viel
mehr wir stellen meisten deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht nutzen wir doch jetzt
mal die chance
du kannst da wir haben das video schon
mal gemacht damals bayerisch du kannst
dich für fünf minuten aussuchen was du
willst und ich verspreche dir in
spätestens einem monat kann ich hier
diese ganzen sachen mitbringen und wir
können ja mal auspacken
weil man muss dazu sagen wir haben es
gemacht da hattest du glaub ich
insgesamt fünf sachen gestellt und davon
später aber das wichtigste das war ja
hört da habe ich auch das geld wieder
bekommen die gab es irgendwie dann hätte
ich nicht mehr ich weiß nicht was ein
bisschen komisch und ich weiß nicht was
ich da noch bestellt ist auf jeden fall
hat es sich nicht gelohnt darüber video
zu machen deswegen würde ich jetzt raten
gestartet jetzt ich mache gleich ein
teil an und dann bestellst du noch mehr
als beim hetzen
logisch ich glaube ich ist ja hier
einmal den rhein weil das ministerium
sich immer nur dann würde ja dann musste
meine männer kategorie gehen bis bereich
oder nicht wissen doch nicht erst
befassen
wer mit der seite damit die checks auf
dieser seite gibt es jetzt nichts
richtig krass teuer ist also hab ich
zumindest noch nicht gefunden
das heißt es kann auch nicht am ende so
castor werden meist auf die plätze
werden wir den teil fertig und los fünf
minuten ab jetzt
ja perfekt frankfurt was waren das jetzt
gerade in waging station aha die kann
man beim iphone nicht sogar benutzende
chat ist wenn man muss das so und jetzt
ein bisschen temperierte weil wir
brauchen noch ein paar sachen berlin ja
so was so gut klingen queen hat dass er
richtig im trend
das hört sich doch gut aus da jetzt
einfach rein du kannst reinhauen
ja wenn sich alle sachen hässlich finde
ich könnte dir einen tipp geben mache
einfach dann öffnen im neuen tab oder im
shop gesucht so weiter weiß
da waren auch schon ein paar vernünftige
chance rein und du nur unvernünftig ja
es sind halt standard shirts weiter
suchen hast du allein zehn sekunden
gebraucht um allein handy case
einzugeben
[Musik]
dass der musikbox gerne ein
spielzeugauto
ich habe mir stehen kommen mit denen ist
also das war letzte woche ich bestelle
dann aber hätte ja aber ich meine du
hast ja du kannst du ja aussuchen was du
willst und du hast ja einfach also du
suchst jetzt noch eben was aber gleich
ist ja die zeit rum
nimm doch einfach alles was der halbwegs
anspricht rein
wir können das auch gern mal oben drehen
und dann mache ich das mal und dann muss
das bezahlen
ok ja das nicht wichtig zu null
irgendwas anständig wer möchte schon
sein
wir sind jetzt gerade bei drei minuten 3
wir können ja sagen machen die sechs
minuten raus matthias frey unterteile
würde ich mal sagen oder
druck kommt mal eine hose und so ist sie
doch so gut aus zumindest auf den fotos
und rein damit jetzt ist dieses jahr mit
rein damit
komm mach doch noch kurz ene mene miste
ist okay und bioshock aber die sieht
geil aus muss ich sagen ich bereit dem
unternehmen droht will ich in dem wollen
doch nicht so im schwarzwald obwohl mir
dass das macht noch mal geld besucher
ist eine bewusste entscheidung oder weiß
weiß auch kein geld ok größe m und rein
in den warenkorb
so langsam nimmt das hier fahrt auf wir
haben jetzt schon vier produkte im
warenkorb jetzt vielleicht noch mal
schuhe bestellt doch mal schuhe dann
auch eine jacke und blauer weil die zeit
läuft ab du hast nach zwei minuten und
betrifft
dann sind auch schuhe nimmt doch jetzt
irgendwelche davon da sind so viele
schuhe ich hätte was ist das denn gut
schießt das war ja das letztlich drauf
gedrückt hätte
naja weiß ich da nicht jeder kannst es
ja neben wenn du willst aber wir waren
doch dazu weiße die da zum beispiel
seiner frauenschuhe mir doch einfach mal
gucken hier die die uhr oder die hier
oder die die sind doch gut aus ja ja ja
ja wir sind absolut ist ja okay da nicht
daran als spuren da hier kommt dann
irgendwie doch jetzt mal trotzdem
hässlich ist
daher komme die hier die sind doch nicht
hässlich klassen der westen nicht und
welche findest du dann davon also von
dem licht von gott her hattest du besser
geworden die man eigentlich ja okay dann
immer keine schuhe alle herzlich ist
aber ziemlich anspruchsvoll
ich glaube ich also ich muss dir das
noch mal irgendwie dabei geht es ja
darum so viel wie möglich dazu bestellen
ich verstehe nicht wieso du also komm du
hast jetzt nicht mal pro minute eine
sache gestellt
[Musik]
das hat niemals so anziehen selbst wenn
ihr aber so ein pulli hier wieso willst
du denn nicht anziehen weil das ist doch
gelacht und kanada
hier steht darauf einen not lacie ja das
ist auch jüngste halte anderen polio nix
drauf stehen habe ich auch schon 20
stück gesehen oder den hier guck mal
diese falten haben ja weil wir sind
jetzt halt schon mal sechs minuten 35
und du hast jetzt wirklich anstrengt nur
vier sachen da drin
wir können jetzt sagen du kannst du noch
zwei sachen aussuchen damit es sinn
macht das wenn die sachen da sind dass
wir auch genug haben zum zeigen weißt du
willst du hier fangen das rennen tun ja
also wenn ich mir halt alles aussuchen
könnte würde ich diesen pulli auf jeden
fall rein tun dass sie trage ich nicht
so etwas grau ist also auf keinen fall
und sonst finden andere sachen aber
damit gemacht aber wir gehen diesmal
also dass hier würde ich direkt rein tun
was ist denn daran hässlich denn hier
würde ich tun
da drin sind den würde ich auf keinen
rein tun da hast du recht dinge würde
ich auch rein tun
deshalb würde ich auch rein tun das sind
ja einfach sachen ihren kommen so ob das
jetzt hast du nicht du hast du
wenigstens auch wenn du da nicht trägt
kann's halt irgendwie man dann schenken
ich weiß ja nicht den gewürdigt anziehen
denn nicht den auch nicht den will ich
anziehen das hier würde ich anziehen und
verschönen also schuhe hatte ich auch
schon fünf fahrer die ich auf jeden fall
anziehen würde
aber wenn du das also dann sucht jetzt
noch zwei sachen aus und dann derart von
weißem pulli wie du hier anders dann
gibts doch da überall so was ähnliches
der sind trotzdem nicht ohne mantel
damit können wir sogar nur 26 euro und
ist schwul dazu und dann haben wir ja
eine gute auswahl und vielleicht noch
ein t shirt mal so ein unzerstörbares
dingen da irgendwie rein nicht dem
vielleicht doch was ist mit dem tattoo
dem rhein figur ist 43 der ist jetzt für
mich grün genau der ist jetzt für mich
und jetzt gehst du immer noch weil hier
nimm doch mal den nie mitnehmen doch
kommen ist jetzt weiß egal das ist jetzt
einfach schuh den probieren wir dann mal
an und wenn du denn nicht ansehen will
ich probiere ich dann aber der ist doch
ist auch irgendwie also ich finde es
eigentlich ganz cool und jetzt haben wir
acht sachen am warenkorb jetzt bestelle
ich dir auch noch eben gucken was kostet
115 euro das ist auf jeden fall eine
ansage aber ich kann noch zwei
zusätzliche videos rausmachen einmal
deine ganzen sachen die so gestellt dass
auspacken und wo wir hier einmal diese
schuhe auspacken 115 euro viele ganzen
sachen darstellt wann kommt es an
ich weiß es nicht super wir haben ihre
zahlungen erhalten
bum bum perfekt ich hoffe ist es in drei
wochen da dann kann man das ja auspacken
jetzt kam es hier also leute das war's
mit dem video
seid gespannt auf den nächsten part ich
freue mich schaut gern bei mir leben bei
instagram vorbei bist du eigentlich da
noch aktiv david styles
wir sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr wieder
gibt's neues video haut rein